when they came back i said what what do
you have in his system they said he had
enough cocaine to kill an elephant
i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is my
stepson derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one
in your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of
them
look at him look at aloha
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner permit
i didn't know there was an ontario
california when i was at ups and i had a
truck yeah uh-huh of ontario ca
that i threw down the international belt
because i thought it was ontario canada
dude
i [ __ ] the whole dare
listen i cost them a lot of i [ __ ] up
the whole system like who the [ __ ]
throwing california by the international
about i was like oh
i was like there's an ontario california
like you son of a [ __ ] um i mean they
had to bring an extra truck around to
unload the mistakes
but i would come in early every night
all the bosses liked me except for one
until later they called me easy money
but i'd come in and i would do
i'd study the sorts and you had to pass
it on this computer system and then they
would let me fill in so once i learned
that they were like you're really good
you should be a supervisor
so i went to supervising i'm 23 years
old and i'm running the whole primary
one that's what i talk about shout out
so it's ups ups
uh baltimore hub it's a hub yeah primary
one was the primary was a primary one
and a primary two that's unload one on
load two i ran primary one at 23 years
old go up to uh olympic and make a left
all right don't ride this guy's ass
[Music]
back then the the cds you could get like
20 for a penny and all that [ __ ] you
know they were a big deal then so people
stole the [ __ ] out i'm talking about the
employees at ups they stole the [ __ ] out
of these things
and once i got as a supervisor the loss
prevention dude this dude was he was a
gangster man he wanted to catch you no
matter what it took he didn't give a
[ __ ] he would sit on an empty metal
package car on the parking lot like off
in the distance landing under a cover
waiting for you to [ __ ] up when it was
like two degrees outside he didn't give
a [ __ ] i was like were you a ux military
or something dude he's like i'll get
their ass i'll get them if they're
stealing so one night
they call me up to the office while
everything's going on they're like come
here i'm like somebody's stealing
they're like yup i go how do you know he
goes i put a pen camera it's the size of
a pen oh yeah a little
camera he did but what they would do is
kick the package they liked outside
and then steal it at the end of the
night they'd walk through security maybe
they made a deal with the security guy
or whatever because this these people
would be on the phone like this uh-huh
they had a wanting them
that's that was security
so the most tight security i've ever
seen yeah so i watch the guy steal he
gets caught red-handed of course they
fire him
another dude timberlands were big back
then especially and the baby blue ones
man yeah and this guy oh went out no
stay here it's fine go up to uh
go up to santa monica make a live this
guy
at the end of the night
takes him puts him on
takes his shoes throws them up on the
roof and then walks out through security
that security guard doesn't know whether
those are his boots or not and boom now
he's off the property so the next day
they're like this dude stole we got a
report from timberland they got some old
nikes i'm like oh who stole them and
they show me i'm like oh man i like him
so this dude is a [ __ ] you to the people
came in wearing the boots to pick up his
last check and i was like they're like
once he's off the property we can't do
anything
he came back wearing the boots and took
us
to get his damn check dude
but they were so creative man there was
a guy creative yeah they were the best
one was i was saying the cds right they
put the dye pack in it finally like the
bag of money but
these two black dudes are unloading and
one of them was crooked but the other
one wasn't but he was in there to get
you know you're teamed up yeah and this
guy rips through a thing and it blows up
on them purple like bad and it's it's a
it's like 100 degrees already plus the
humidity and in those trucks it's like
15 20 degrees hotter and you're sweating
and the worst thing you can do is rub it
and this dude is rubbing it it's all
over them so they come up to the office
and i can't stop laughing
he's like stop [ __ ] funny i'm like it
is so funny dude it is so funny the way
you look it's ridiculous over cds
but loss prevention was catching every
one of these [ __ ] this dude
he was gangster he was saving baltimore
ups a lot of [ __ ] money you're gonna
make a left of that light up there
[Music]
all right that was a nice turn
another guy would do meth or something
man he would come in and he would crank
he was the best unloader he would crank
packages out like ah they would have to
put three guys swording him usually it's
one to one it was one to three he would
pump him out so he'd come out
doing all i'm like what the [ __ ] he
looks like he's blue and gray and she
looked awful sweat and i was like you're
gonna kill that guy like throws a hammer
right there that guy's a hammer put the
hammer in there he'd just be drinking
gatorade and put it down are you ready
and then
all night long
so finally
i was like look man you're gonna kill
this kid he's definitely on something
see the guy has his blinker on yeah see
what i'm talking about i never trust a
blinker right there it is
so they sent him to go get tested and
then when they came back i said what
what do you have in his system they said
he had enough cocaine to kill an
elephant
he had coke and meth he was just in
there cranking and smoking it and just
banging on his back he was a he was a
hammer though that guy probably dead now
[Music]
[Music]
you